et on va plus loin avec à mes côtés
aujourd'hui annie va reporter de guerre
indépendante bonjour anne ribes on sort
et virginie herz de la rédaction de
france 24 reporter également et
présentatrice de l'émission actuelle sur
notre antenne un mot d'abord de notre
confrère frédéric leclerc imhoff 8e
journalistes tués en ukraine depuis le
début de la guerre déclenchée par la
russie ce journaliste reporter d'image
pour la chaîne bfm tv est mort touché
par un éclat d'obus alors qu'il filmait
des civils en train d'évacuer près de
severodonezk la ville que les russes
tentent actuellement dans ces rhdp dans
la région de lougansk première
dirigeante française à faire le
déplacement dans le pays la nouvelle
ministre des affaires étrangères
catherine colonna appelle à une enquête
dans les meilleurs délais et coûter
tant qu'elle sera menée par les
autorités ukrainiennes c'est une zone
d'ailleurs qui n'est pas accessible
quelques zones de combat et nous serons
lien par le canal de l'ambassade par le
centre spécialisé du quai d'orsay pour
avoir les remontées d'informations sur
les circonstances précises qui sont
celles que vous connaissez un convoi qui
par un journaliste qui insiste pour
noter dans ce convoi est malheureusement
un obus qui tombe à proximité qui le
blesse mortellement n vous allez réagir
à ce que dit la ministre vous étiez
vous-même en ukraine au début du mois ce
drame vous évoque forcément quelque
chose de familier quand on est en zone
de guerre comme le dombass la mort c'est
un risque permanent
ben oui oui ça va oui une guerre séguin
il ya des morts et et malheureusement
notre confrère est mort
en faisant ce métier ce métier admirable
ce métier qu'il faut continuer à faire
et moi je ne suis pas d'accord quand
j'entends la ministre dire que ce cette
route n'était pas accessible c'est pas
vrai elle était accessible pour nous
autres journalistes comme frédéric qui
avait demandé l'autorisation je sais
qu'il était avec une unité de police qui
l'accompagnait parce qu'il faut bien le
dire il ya aucun journaliste en ukraine
qui va comme ça sur le front comme une
fleur sur le flanc comme si c'était
facile justement ce n'est pas facile les
l'armée ukrainienne les forces de
sécurité ukrainienne contrôle et
accompagne les journalistes qui vont sur
place et notamment les journalistes de
télévision donc ils étaient là ils
avaient le droit d'être là il faisait
son métier et et il s'est pris un éclat
d'obus voilà voilà ce qui s'est passé
c'est effectivement un risque ici on y
penser tous les ans civile vous diriez
que les rudes vise délibérément les
civils pour mary de l'avis des
journalistes y compris en sage un peux
pas le dire on n'est pas il me semble
dans le cas de notre consoeur
israélienne qui est un pardon notre
consoeur palestinienne qui est morte
justement parce qu'elle avait été visée
par un sniper israélien
il y a quelques semaines là c'est pas du
tout les mêmes circonstances et
d'ailleurs on les a pas encore tout à
fait clair si les circonstances
d'aujourd'hui mais d'après ce qu'on sait
il n'était pas seul son son collègue son
binôme était avec lui il a été blessé à
la jambe mais dieu merci il va bien il y
avait également aussi leur fixeur
interprète une jeune femme ukrainienne
et puis s'il était dans un convoi
humanitaire dans un bus qui faisait
sortir des gens de seven and yet pour
aller sur cette route delà de la vie
justement dans en sécurité il y avait
d'autres personnes et en imaginant que
le bus était identifié comme tel il ya
donc un risque manifeste prix à mesa les
auteurs de ce bombardement mais il y a
c'est la guerre raphaël c'est la guerre
c'est la guerre c'est pas la première
fois ni la dernière que je dis dans tous
les pays les guerres que j'ai couverte
que ce soit l'ukraine la tchétchénie
avant l'irak l'afghanistan c'est ya des
oui tous ceux qui sont dehors du théâtre
des opérations disent y'a pas de il ya
des règles de la guerre oui mais quand
on est sur le terrain il y en a plus y
en a plus ces simples perdants on
appelle ça soit bavure soit frappe
intentions exactement tout cas c'est la
réalité virginie vous avez à vous aussi
un couvert plusieurs conflits comme
journaliste reporter d'image est grand
reporter le risque zéro n'existe pas en
zone de guerre n'aurait effectivement un
niveau et je ne peux qu'acquiescer le
risque zéro n'existe pas ce qu'il ya
c'est que quand on est sur le terrain
sur un terrain de conflit on évalue en
permanence de risque on évalue en
parlant avec vous avez parlé de fixeur
donc c'est souvent les personnes locales
et journalistes locaux qui nous
accompagnent qui aidera traduire qui
connaissent bien le terrain localement
on parle avec ses confrères avec ses
consoeurs on parle avec les gens du coin
aussi pour savoir comment est la
situation c'est une évaluation
permanente du risque et une fille née en
fait généralement on se décide d'aller
quelque part ou pas c'est une intuition
on se dit je me fais confiance ou pas et
il ya parfois on le sent pas parfois le
sens et parfois on n'a pas de chance et
c'est comme ça donc on l'intègre
lorsqu'on est sur le champ de bataille y
compris en zone urbaine oui absolument
dans toute zone de tension en fait tout
simplement c'est que oui effectivement
ça peut arriver face à ce risque faut-il
limiter and la liberté de mouvement de
nos reporters qui t'a restreint les
récits les emails non mais sûrement paul
enfin seulement là moi c'est une horreur
d'entendre ça je ne peux passer on a
déjà tellement peu d'informations dès
qu'on est sur une zone de guerre vous
voyez bien qu'on a propagande contre
propagande mais ça je dirais c'est de
bonne guerre
toutes les guerres sont comme ça sur je
veux dire les militaires les militaires
font de la propagande mais nous
journalistes nous ne sommes pas
militaire nous ne sommes nous ne sommes
pas partie prenante dans cette guerre
nous essayons de de saisir d'aller
chercher des faits on ne peut que quand
on y va on ne dit pas que quand on y va
sur le terrain on trouve tout et on
trouve la vérité avec un grand v mais au
moins comme virginie vient de le dire on
jauge et on revient avec des histoires
humaines qui sont celles de la guerre la
guerre c'est pas simplement justement
des décomptes de blessés et de morts et
de tanks et de etc d'artillerie c'est
comment vivent les gens dans la guerre
qu'est ce qu'ils en pensent comment ils
vont s'en sortir et c'est ce qu'il était
en train de faire c'est et on ne peut
pas profiter de cela vous savez ce
discours j'ai entendu tout le temps la
guerre en irak la guerre en afghanistan
tout le temps des caves et des
kidnappings journalistes tous eu des
morts de journaliste on en profitait
pour éventuellement poser la question
qui en ait plus mais comme en france il
ya plus journalistes sur le terrain
comment on fera comment fera pour 20 des
informations est là pour moi ya pas de
débat effectivement on peut pas limiter
le même au nom de la protection de vue
au nom de la protection de tout à
l'heure tarek notre confrère a dit par
exemple ici à france médias monde il ya
un accompagnement sécuritaire pour
limite et au maximum de risques limités
oui mais c'est voilà après sur place on
peut pas interdire enfin on peut
interdire mais dans ce cas on interdit l
information et le libre accès à
l'information on l'a vu en tout cas
catherine colonna dont fraîchement nommé
s'est rendu à kiev aujourd'hui et abuja
à proximité donc de la capitale où a eu
lieu ont eu lieu même des massacres
attribués aux troupes russes on s'est
longtemps demandé si si emmanuel macron
ferait le déplacement c'est important
que la ministre française à yann c'est à
dire que là effectivement on pensait
tous quand même qu'après sa réélection
emmanuel macron allait peut-être même se
précipiter entre guillemets à kiev comme
l'ont fait d'autres dirigeants européens
et des états unis mais il n'en a pas il
n'y est pas allé donc du coup ça
devenait un petit peu justement gênant
d'ailleurs les ukrainiens l'ont dit ils
n'étaient pas tout à fait content de
voir que justement emmanuel macron
n'adoptez pas tout à fait la rhétorique
de génocide qui est celle le mot employé
par joe biden ne venait pas rencontré
les skis à kiev maquereau a envoyé sa
nouvelle ministre des affaires
étrangères on va voir ce que ça va
donner en tout cas c'est important
qu'elle soit là bien sûr et tout à
l'heure dans une interview elle a dit
qu'elle avait été envoyé à la demande du
président de la république pour montrer
visible pour rendre visible l'amitié que
la france avait pu voir la roue
l'ukraine pour effectivement lui avais
déjà dit rien que si cela peut être
utile donc ça veut dire que tu dis non
mais en tout cas ce qu'elle disait ce
qu'elle dit elle la ministre des
affaires étrangères c'est que pour le
moment elle voit que ni les russes ni
les ukrainiens ne sont d'accord pour
dialoguer et elle comprend leur position
en tout cas la position ukrainienne mais
elle insiste sur le fait que le dialogue
va devoir être nécessaires à un moment
donné que c'est peut-être pas le moment
et que la france continue à se
positionner comme un intermédiaire
possible ou un médiateur possible elle
continue à développer la politique
évidemment des manuels macron et puis
c'est emmanuel macron d'ne n'a pas
visiblement envie de froisser moscou
c'est surtout cela c'est à dire si
emmanuel macron à l'est uniquement à
kiev sans passer par moscou il ya tout
un ordre commencerait-il par moscou
parquet a fait que c'était on l'a vu
avec d'autres dirigeants européens
et bien pour le moment il n'a rien
décidé mais c'est notre nouvelle
ministre affaires étrangères qui y va
donc c'est quand même un signal positif
de bonne volonté donné par la france à
un moment qui n'est pas facile pour pour
kiev aujourd'hui alors on va évoquer
peut-être le terrain dans un instant
mais emmanuel macron lui il était à
bruxelles au même moment avec 26 autres
chefs d'état et de gouvernement
européens principal sujet de négociation
y aura-t-il un embargo sur les pétrole
russe la plupart sont pour la hongrie
elle traîne les pieds pour cause elle
importe les deux tiers de son pétrole de
russie via l'oléoduc droujba écouter au
sol avant de rien à son arrivée à
bruxelles suivi du premier ministre
hongrois viktor orban
nous avons maintenant pratiquement
résolu tous les problèmes sauf un et
c'est la question du pétrole brut qui
transitent par oléoduc est ici les
discussions sont toujours en cours je
n'ai pas trop d'espoir c'est nous
puissions résoudre cette question dans
les prochaines 48 heures
il n'y a pas du tout de compromis pour
le moment il n'y a donc pas d'accord du
tout
je viens juste de recevoir le texte il
n'ya bien sûr aucun accord
virginia ce que réclame victor aubaine
pour s'aligner sur les européens alors
officiellement ils demandent qu'à 30
transition pour et puis de l'argent au
800 millions pour adapter son économie
mais en fait ils profitent de la
situation lui qui est mis au ban de
l'union européenne parce que l'union
européenne critique sa gestion de l'état
de droit de la démocratie en général des
libertés individuelles et la commission
européenne qui depuis novembre bloc le
versement de 7 2 milliards d'euros qui
sont dû normalement oz post post coït
donc là il n'en profite évidemment pour
dire bon bah voilà c'est ça le marché
c'est moi je veux bien
éventuellement ne plus être dépendant du
pétrole russe mais en échange il va
falloir faire des gestes à ne vous
comprenez le premier wallon n'ont pas la
personne durban mais les intérêts de la
hongrie dans cette affaire chaque
dirigeant défend les intérêts de son
pays donc effectivement sorbonne il est
connu pour ça ça aurait été autre
étonnant que tout d'un coup ils soient
d'accord mais ce que je trouve plus
ennuyeux c'est quand même les failles
que cela réveille le au sein de l'union
européenne et je crois que c'est
vraiment un problème qu'on n'aura pas
fini de régler qui est un problème clé
voyez à quel point les pays baltes sont
mécontents justement du fait que mon
corps ban soit en train de semer la
zizanie les pays baltes la lituanie la
lettonie l'estonie sont mécontents du
coup de fil qu'à passer emmanuel macron
avec olaf scholz ce week end à vladimir
poutine pour parler de ce problème eux
ce sont passés du gaz russe selon était
archi dépendant absolument ils sont sont
passés et donc nous avons là d'aider des
dissonances qui sont plus que ça et on
se demande comment ça va comment on va
faire pour continuer à avancer d'une
seule voix dans cette union européenne
avec l'ukraine qui est un terrain de
bataille qui ne va pas cesser de l'être
dans les mois à venir et on va devoir
décider bientôt je crois que c'est au
mois de juin du statut de la candidature
de l'ukraine à l'union européenne avec
d'ici là peut-être une russie qui aura
mis la main sur une partie du nom bave
pas tous pas tout la russie avance très
lentement
dans cette partie du débat severodonetsk
et n'est pas encore complètement aux
mains des russes c'est la salle dernière
grande ville sous contrôle l'ukrainien
de cette partie de l'est du donbass
mais il reste quand même une grande
partie dans le dôme basse qui sont avec
deux villes importantes qui sont slavia
nk et crame à tort sq et qui sont encore
loin disons des positions russes mais il
me semble que les l'armée ukrainienne va
faire ce qu'elle a fait précédemment
c'est à dire se battre
ac-v redonner à ce qu'elle est en train
de faire vous m'aimez mais sont retiré
au dernier moment pour éviter les pertes
finales et est finalement reculé et
continuer sur d'autres positions c'est
sans doute ce qui va se passer ce qui
permet aussi aux ukrainiens d'attirer ou
de maintenir la paix les principales
forces russes dans au même endroit même
en bas au même endroit un mot pour finir
c'est beaucoup plus léger évidemment
même si ça s'est quand même mal terminée
du fiasco du week-end et les incidents
qui ont émaillé la finale de ligue des
champions disputée ici au stade de
france après avoir été à des programmes
et du lieu d'origine saint pétersbourg
on revient toujours à la guerre en
ukraine ce match a débuté avec 36
minutes de retard pour cause de panique
au portique de sécurité en cause selon
le ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin une fraude massive de faux
billets qu'il attribue aux supporters
britanniques
écoutez le mini suivi de la ministre des
sports madame oudéa castéra ce qui a été
constaté c'est une fraude massive
industriel est organisé de faux billets
puisque les prêts filtrage évoquée par
les stadiers par le stade de france et
la fédération française de football
prévoit plus de 70% de faux billets à
l'entrée du stade de france puis une
fois passé ce prêt filtrage elle a été
constaté plus de 15% de faux billets
également après les premiers prêts
filtrage puis c'est à dire plus de 2600
chiffre confirmé par l'uefa de billets
non validées alors même qu'ils avaient
passé le premier filtrage on doit
prendre la mesure de l'ensemble des
choses qui se sont passées ce qu'il faut
vraiment avoir en tête c'est qu'il ya eu
d'abord cet afflux de supporters
britanniques du club de liverpool sans
billet ou avec des billets falsifiés il
ya eu un amas je pense que d'ailleurs le
fait que le club du real madrid est à ce
point encadrer la venue de ses
supporters à paris en prévoyant les bus
depuis l'aéroport
d'organiser tous vraiment d'un point à
un autre ce qui est tranche radicalement
avec ce qu'a fait le club l'hiver de
liverpool qu'elle laissait ses
supporters dans la nature à créer une
différence majeure la faute à liverpool
a on l'a compris alors là du côté
anglais on se dit extrêmement déçu du
traitement infligé aux supporters
anglais qui croire virgin hier
c'est un peu court jeune homme c'est un
petit peu facile de pas du tout à faire
son mea culpa y avait quand même
beaucoup d'éléments qui pouvait être
anticipés notamment cette vente de faux
billets alors le chiffre est encore à
évaluer il ya une enquête là-dessus mais
il y a eu une des notes de la police
disant il n'y aura beaucoup de
supporters qui n'auront pas de billets
donc ça on le savait on savait qu'il y
avait des problèmes sur le rer aussi
donc ça ça aurait pu être également otis
ip on sait aussi que les supporters de
liverpool ne sont pas les plus doux on
va dire qu'ils sont plutôt virulent et
on sait aussi que autour du stade de
france quand il n'y a disons un petit
peu d'échauffourées ça a fait un appel
d'air et en l'occurrence à un moment
donné il ya eu une levée des barrages
filtrants ce qui a attiré une population
qui déjeunent qui avait tout d'un coup
ils envie d'aller profiter de l'occasion
pour aller voir le match d'autres pour
voler des portables il ya eu beaucoup de
vols à l'arraché à l'occasion est
effectivement tout était enfin s'essayer
eu plein dans ce monde un enchaînement
mais qui aurait pu être anti ça fait
quand même mauvais effet à deux ans des
jo de paris un nom bien sûr bien sûr
c'est ce que c'est ce que tout le monde
y met et je crois qu'il faut quand même
se dire que les jeux olympiques
justement seront préparés puisque là on
en vient la russie c'est vrai que au
lieu d'avoir un an pour préparer cette
rencontre de samedi soir ils ont eu à
peine trois mois donc les jeux
olympiques c'est pas du tout ça et puis
c'est sans doute pas le même public les
personnes qui vont ce ne sont pas des
fans clubs ça n'a rien à voir ce sont
pas des mii ce sont des gens qui
viennent voir l'olympisme dont clients
et puis seront beaucoup plus nombreux on
peut espérer on veut que notre pays où
il sera à la hauteur on l'espère aussi
merci anne nivat d'avoir été avec tout
ce soir dans on va plus loin merci
virgin et fc la fin de cette émission
restez avec nous dans trois minutes un
nouveau journal
[Musique]